[Applause]
this is something that i have to bring
up
and then we can talk about it very
briefly but i have to bring this up
because it drove me [ __ ] crazy
okay this drove me crazy
i know i can tell i can already tell you
wound up boy i'm wound the [ __ ] up
okay i thought that there is a very
organic symbiotic relationship
between ig thoughts and me
okay right what's that relationship the
relationship is
you thought it up and i
objectify that seems like it's not just
a relationship with you
it seems like it's the relationship
relationship right
yeah i'm a great strong faithful man
correct i look at a couple of these
thoughts but you don't search for them
they just pop up
they pop up i also follow sometimes
i don't follow anything new it's been
grandfathered in yeah okay
and honestly some of them they get um
sent to the wayside
i've unfollowed yep do you know what i
mean i only keep the
top shelf look at that
for my relationship creme de la creme
you know i would never disrespect my
girl by following new
yeah new is crazy that's crazy but if i
carried it in you knew this about me and
it's like a it's like a friendship
almost
except we've been together for years
i've been following these girls in their
swimwear
brands they're trying to get off the
ground for years yeah okay
every ig thought got a swimwear brand
mark yep they would be so upset to lose
you as a follower they would
be upset to lose me as a follower right
because i thought the relationship was
you [ __ ] it up i objectify the
sluttiness ladies listen right now tell
me if i'm off
taylor listen to me right now tell me if
i'm up there's girls they're literally
posting the most salacious sexualized
pictures you could possibly imagine
okay okay okay i observe
because they are salacious and sexual
okay
that's fair that's fair everybody's
happy happy
maybe the occasional double tap to raise
their self-esteem which is clearly low
i would never do such a thing but if i
do because i'm trembling as i'm looking
at it might happen
that's a terrifying second bro when you
double tap my accident
oh you know you're looking first thing
in the morning your fingers haven't woke
up yet
and you're just scrolling through you're
like untapped before your girl wake up
your thumbs are mad horny
she's right here okay
this is the problem i have yeah when
the ig thoughts can't accept
their role in the ecosystem you monetize
the thottiness
i'm okay if you embrace that right
horrible decisions embraces it it's
beautiful
beautiful it's happy it's great they own
the word [ __ ]
correct i'm following these thoughts
that i thought were on the same page
okay i thought they were on this i
thought they understood
you are objectifying yourself and i will
objectify you in return as you wish
right
i see a post today from one of them
the post says stop
this is some quote [ __ ] you know they
love leave them quotes
they love these quotes it goes stop
sexualizing the naked female
wait for it stop sexualizing the naked
female the female body is art
to me showing off my body is not about
being sexy
it's about being and feeling beautiful
there is so much aesthetic with the
female frame i'm obsessed with that
sometimes it's
abstract art and beauty i believe in
being confident in every form the very
next slide
is swipe up for my only fans you [ __ ]
fraud
taylor tell me if i'm wrong
why can't she accept it it's like a fish
that's trying to walk on land
why is she so she thinks sexy and
beautiful is two different things abby
she doesn't want to be
a [ __ ] but she is no no
no you're saying she's a [ __ ] because
of the pictures no i no no no
but i don't know how many guys she [ __ ]
i can't say she's a [ __ ] but that's
that's not saying that's
a sex worker she's a sex worker you're a
you're a sex worker you are
selling sex for money right yes
is it sex yes it sucks why is it
maybe that penis is not going in exactly
but you can't say
only nudes is for sex workers and then
when someone's on only news selling knew
it'd be like that's not a sex worker
not only quotes
[Applause]
everybody says only fans is for sex
workers it's a safe space for sex
workers and then when
somebody tries to go that's not a sex
worker they're like whoa what are you
doing you're [ __ ] up the space for
sex workers none of a [ __ ] is selling
nudes
on only fans how's she not a sex worker
with you being a sex worker i'm okay
with you objectifying yourself
i'm open this is not only am i okay with
it i love it
i love to take part in that relationship
this is beautiful
you're the flower i'm the bee
i gotta pollinate you
[Music]
[Applause]
gotta get some pollen in your nose
god bless you yes he did
some people getting corona out here
[Laughter]
so my point is i'm so upset with the
fraudulence it's art it's first of all
let's talk about art
art is an object to be objectified oh
[ __ ] you are funny what do art
what do we do with our we look at that
[ __ ] and judge it
and objectify it you are calling
yourself art you're calling yourself a
[ __ ] object you're acting like art is
better
i don't beat my dick to art
jackson pollock looked like he bit his
dick on his heart
that helped maybe that's her real talk
maybe that's her point i just think it's
absurd
and it drives me crazy and it's this
[ __ ] where like
you think you're above the thoughts
you think you're one step above a
thought because it's art
no you're not you are one of
and that is fine and accept it and love
it
if somebody won't tell me oh yeah you
just tell dick jokes
yes sir i do
love it happy to do it hey you're not
gonna find me all i do is
intellectual social commentary [ __ ] you
suck my dick
it might be part of it but i'm a thought
for this comedy baby
we laugh thoughts yo we love laughs of
course does it drive you crazy when you
see that
you're a hard-working woman with a real
[ __ ] job this ain't real but it's
close
you got other real jobs you've got other
real jobs and you see these girls trying
to call themselves artists
that would bother me you got a think pad
you think them [ __ ] got a pink pad
for work please put that
[Laughter]
no but i mean so she has a sexy
new picture up i'm trying to understand
that they're
crazy nudes are great he has a post
that's just words like don't objectify
me
i'm an artist the female body is art
that's why i love it it makes me feel
empowered i mean
then the post before that is literally
the pose after it
after it after swipe up for my only fans
that's dumb that's [ __ ] that's what
we're saying
come on same but it's the same thing for
instance if i was to put up
a picture of me in a bikini i know the
[ __ ] i'm doing exactly
that's all we said that's all we're
saying
like and we appreciate it it's another
thing if like it's a just a portrait
picture of me and then they say
something objective yeah
i don't like that [ __ ] like if i'm
sweating that's there and you see that
[ __ ] that girth
this is you showing the corn the corn
cubs yeah i'm saying
yeah if it's time to harvest
yeah you got the cornucopia if the
cornucopia is poppin
you know if you throw that [ __ ] in a
microwave and you hear a pop-pop pop 30
seconds later
where's orville redenbacher yeah where's
orville
yeah put some butter got some salt and
butter yeah cause this movie's about to
get started
i know what i'm doing hey i'm
photoshopping because i ain't got it
like that
let's be honest here
you